le bal le film le plus original de
l'année a valu à son réalisateur étant
escola le césar de la meilleure mise en
scène et le prix du meilleur film le bal
c'est scandés par les pas des habitués
d'un dancing histoire à la fois ironique
et attendri des français de 1936 à nos
jours
son césar du meilleur film scola devra
le partager avec maurice pialat ex-aequo
pour à nos amours
déjà récompensé par le prix delluc c'est
l'histoire d'une jeune fille qui cherche
l'amour à travers des aventures aussi
nombreuses que décevante sandrine
bonnaire la jeune actrice du film 10
septembre ex apprentie coiffeuse sans
aucune expérience du cinéma
il montre des dons si éclatant qu'elle
remporte le prix du meilleur jeune
espoir féminin
mais quand même je pas les faire à la
barbie qui vont arriver coûte la
prochaine fois que je fais un crocodile
jeunes et étranglent côté mal c'est
tchao pantin qui a pris le monopole
trois césars pour deux interprètes
seulement coluche en ne faisant pas rire
cagnes prix du meilleur acteur et
richard anconina en rafle deux d'un coup
celui du meilleur second rôle et celui
du meilleur jeune espoir
qu'est ce que c'est que ça c'est de la
vraie croix saint geoirs adjoint ça
commence par un joint on sait comment ça
finit 1
mais sarah pour l'année de quoi quel
effort tu as vu ce que tu t'en fais tout
et huit mois d'habitude tous les jours
ex électricien et animateur pour voyage
du troisième âge anconina est venu au
spectacle à 25 ans sans avoir passé par
l'observatoire
à chacun sa merde il ya des rôles que
vous voulez jouer
oui j'aimerais jouer c'est moi jouer un
musicien aveugle je m'intéresserai
beaucoup c'est moi jouer un homme de loi
soit son avocat ou soit un juge
j'aimerais jouer aussi après être
visitée après parce que je j'ai été très
impressionné par par un film ou jouer
montgomery clift où il joue un prêtre